Entrance to the paint
ball court costs $5,
and paint balls are
paid for separately.
A ticket for entrance with 5
balls, for example, costs $8.
So let's define
some variables here.
Let's let p equal
the price that I'm
paying for admission
and the balls.
And let's let b equal the number
of balls-- number of balls.
And we know that
the price is going
to be a function of
the number of balls.
We could make a
little table here.
So let's make a table where,
for a given number of balls,
let's figure out what
the price is going to be.
So let's just start at 0 balls.
If we have 0 balls,
we have to pay just
to get into the paint ball
court, and that costs us $5.
Now they tell us a ticket
for entrance with 5 balls--
so now we have
entrance and 5 balls--
this is going to cost $8.
So let's think about what the
incremental price per ball
here.
And we're going to assume
that the price per ball
is constant after you pay
for admission, after you
pay this first $5.
So What's.
The price per ball?
Well, when our number
of balls increase by 5,
our price increases by
$3-- by $3, so plus 3.
So we could say
our change in price
over the change in the number
of balls is equal to our change
in price is $3, when our
change in the balls are 5.
So this right over
here, you could
view this as your
unit price per ball--
your unit rate of change
of price per ball.
This is going to be $0.60
per ball-- $0.60 per ball.
So let's think about
constructing an equation that
represents how much we will
pay as a function of balls.
And we could write it in
function notation, if we like.
We could write price
as a function of balls
is going to be equal to.
Well, you're going to
start off just paying
$5 just for getting
into the place.
So you're going to
start off getting $5,
and then you're
going to pay more
depending on the number
of balls you get.
And you're going to
pay $0.60 per ball.
You see that right over here.
When you've got 5
balls, you paid $3.
$3 for 5 balls is the same
thing as $0.60 per ball.
So you're then going to pay
$0.60 per ball after that.
So this right over here is
the equation that represents--
or that's a way of defining
price as a function of balls.
And we can also try to graph it.
So let's do that.
So let's actually try
to graph it, as well.
So that's our price
axis, our vertical axis.
And let's say this is
the number of balls axis.
So this is balls, and this
is price as a function--
as a function of balls.
So when the balls are 0--
let me do this in a color
I haven't used yet.
When the balls are 0, the price,
we've already seen, is $5.
Let's say this is $5,
this is $10, this is $15.
So when we have 0 balls,
we're going to pay $5.
And then when you see when
we have 5 balls-- so let's
say that this is 5 right over
here-- when you have 5 balls,
we paid $8, which gets
us right around here.
And two points define a
line, so this function
is a linear function, and it
would look something like this.
And if you ask, what is
the slope of this line?
Well, the slope is
the rate of change
of the vertical axis with
respect to the horizontal axis.
So what is that?
So in the horizontal
axis-- and frankly,
we've already calculated this.
When the horizontal axis changed
by 5, when your change in b
is equal to 5, your vertical
axis-- so your vertical axis.
So your change in
price was equal to $3.
price over your change
in the number of
balls, which would
be the change in
the vertical axis
over the change in the
horizontal axis, which
is the definition of slope.
It's a way of defining the
inclination of this line.
That is going to be equal
to 3 over 5-- 3 over 5,
which is exactly what we
calculated right over here,
just thinking about it in
a slightly different way.
Now we've thought about
this in multiple ways.
Let's actually try to
answer their questions.
Let's figure out which
of these actually apply.
So the first is that the
relationship is proportional.
So if we had a proportional
relationship between the two,
this function would
look like this.
It would be p is equal
to some constant times
the number of balls.
And by definition, in a
proportional relationship--
in a proportional relationship--
when your number of balls is 0,
price would be 0.
And that's not the
scenario we have here.
When your balls are 0,
you're still paying $5.
So this, this is
not-- this is not--
a proportional relationship.
Next statement-- entrance
with 10 balls cost $16.
Well, we can test that out.
When b equals 10-- So the price
for 10 balls is going to be
equal to 5 plus 0.60 times 10.
Well, this is 5 plus 6,
which is equal to 11, not 10.
So this isn't right, either.
When the number of
balls increases by 11,
the price increases by $6.60.
So remember, the change
in price over the change
in the number of
balls is going to be
equal to-- let we get it
right in a good color here.
So let me write it here.
The change in price over the
change in the number of balls
is always going to
be equal to 3/5.
And so, they say number
of balls increases by 11.
So 3/5 is equal to what over 11?
So let's think about
that a little bit.
So 3/5 is equal to-- well,
let's write it this way.
3/5 is the same
thing as 0.6, so let
me write this-- 0.6 is equal
to the price change over 11.
And I'll just write that
as a question mark--
as a question mark over 11.
You multiply both
sides by 11, you
get 6.6 is equal
to question mark.
So this is absolutely true.
The price increases by $6.60
when the number of balls
increases by 11.
So this one right over
here is absolutely true.
And then finally, when
the x-axis represents
the number of paint
balls, the slope
of the graph of the
relationship is 5/3.
Well here, we did
represent the x-axis
as the number of paint
balls-- or the horizontal axis
as the number of paint balls--
but our slope wasn't 5/3.
It was 3/5.
So this last statement
is absolutely not right.
So this is the only one
that we can say applies.